c'est erwan on vient pour l'ambiance
conviviale les escargots c'est pour les
doulas et vous partager ou par les
enfants nous donne de ses réponses pour
l'infatigable chef globalement ils ont
l'air content
et je n'ose pas dire le contraire on
peut les desserts encore pour la bonne
nourriture toi j'avais quelqu'un qui
était là la semaine dernière même si
j'ai l'impression d'être chez mes
parents comme on faisait il ya 50 ans il
ya 60 ans c'est à dire une proximité
avec les gens des vrais produits des
prépas déconnant
et surtout une ambiance qui est
extrêmement familiale quoi ici le
tutoiement est obligatoire on mange des
produits cuits au feu de bois et
particularités de la maison c'est le
client qui va chercher sa bouteille à la
cave c'est très simple le patron nous
conseille il nous dit va chercher la
bouteille et
et puis on a le serveur qui nous la
donne qui nous livre qui avait déjà la
bouteille en main avant qu'on arrive
quoi si ce restaurant au coeur du bourg
donner un village de 500 habitants fait
salle pleine midi et soir c'est parce
qu'il est devenu célèbre grâce à une
blogueuse c'est comme ça quand je veux
penser comme adresse les adresses où on
se prend pas la tête on ferait plaisir
on mange bien et où il ya une espèce de
grande fraternité une vidéo vue plus de
37 millions de fois et qui fait déplacer
les clients on vient de toulouse via
paris mais voilà on a on s'est dit qu'on
devait tester
l'ambiance et le restaurant est ce que
la nourriture c'est un truc de fou on
avait vu la leur portage sur youtube
mais c'est pour ça nous on a fait 150
kilomètres pour venir là en fait on fait
bordeaux lille et on est venu exprès on
a fait le détour par ici pour découvrir
l'endroit je suis extrêmement flatté
j'ai l'impression d'être une grande
personne mais que c'est pas loin c'est
fou mais ce qu'il flatte aussi c'est
quand tu es un grand cuisinier qui bien
qu'ils embrassent épouse chez toi c'est
moi toi ça c'est un bonheur à tous parce
qu on fait quoi on n'est qu'une auberge
dans le trou du cul du monde et i vêlas
dans un bled de 500 habitants étaient
les gens qui viennent nous voir que
j'aime passer du temps qui a priori on a
l'air d'avoir un peu de plaisir ouais et
ça c'est ça qui est important attention
si vous voulez venir manger ici il faut
prendre ses précautions car le
restaurant et complète très rapidement
là